it's a story unlike any other a
shipwreck forces a boy named pie and a
tiger named Richard Parker onto a small
Lifeboat where they must co-exist to
survive now with state-of-the-art
puppetry and stagecraft that story is on
Broadway our Jamie wax went behind the
scenes for a look at how the life of pie
comes alive on stage
from Jan Martell's 14 million plus
selling Global sensation of a novel
to director Ang Lee's 11 time
oscar-nominated film version
to the current stage hit
the Life of Pi has captivated audiences
with a tale of literal captivity Iran
avasikara has portrayed the Title
Character since the original production
in Sheffield England where it was clear
from the first performance that they
were going somewhere at the end of it
that was a roll of like a thousand
tigers in the audience you know
and when the lights came back on and we
ran for the curtain call everybody was
on their feet
going absolutely berserk and at that
moment I think we all thought oh wow we
have something special that could that
could take us places those places
included London's West End where the
production received five Olivier Awards
including best new play this is very
overwhelming best actor for avicara and
a highly unusual best supporting actor
award for the seven-member puppetry team
which included Scarlett wilderink
how has this production come together so
beautifully cohesively to tell a very
simple but complicated story I mean I
could name a thousand things there's
lots of people working together
designers makers
sculptors actors so many people
backstage and on stage and I think
there's also a little magical thing to
when you get all of the right people in
those places at the same time in the
same place
that place is now Broadway where
wolderink says the play has continued to
evolve you don't just make the show and
then the show's the show like you you
make it and then it starts then the work
starts because your understanding of the
animal gets deeper
your understanding of the connection of
the animal with the same partner or
anything else on stage is deeper
the thoughts become clearer you start to
think more about the psychology of the
animal
more about why exactly he's doing
everything that he's doing why does he
put that ball there you know everything
they do is efficient and uh and
everything is for a reason even more so
than humans honest aren't they yes yeah
exploring those themes of human and
animal nature the story centers around a
boy named pie Patel and a Bengal tiger
named Richard Parker who struggled to
stay alive while adrifted sea on a small
boat it was adapted for stage by Lolita
chakra barti and features puppets
designed by Finn Caldwell and Nick
Barnes that come startlingly to life
with the puppeteers fully visible
there's something very cool about
declaring us because it makes the
audience feel comfortable that we're not
trying to hide anything from them
and when Richard Parker makes his
appearance the audience Like Pie has a
visceral reaction
when the tiger Roars or the Tiger growls
all of the sounds are made by the
puppeteers correct that's right all
right so let's hear a tiger roar guys
okay I'm leaving goodbye thank you very
much this was nice a quick run although
he spent his childhood in Sri Lanka
rather than India Abba Sakara feels a
strong connection to the character he
plays I grew up a lot in my grandparents
Village in Arizona and my parents were
separating so I spent a lot of time
there and it was just them too and I
mean I look back and
it was kind of like out of a book really
like I was climbing trees and I spent
hours and hours just like and my main
challenge was like being able to climb
to the top and wait till the wind would
sway one top Tree Top to the other top
and I would cross and my grandmother
used to hate it obviously but I think
that thrill was like being on a ship
and like another young man who sets out
on a ship
he too has been changed by his voyage I
read the novel after I got the job but
that connection was very quick I think
it was because of the Civil War that was
going on during that time and I was
quite confused by these groups of people
who looked the same were trying to kill
each other and so when this came on
there were lots of connections that
happened and some of it I had that
Curiosity that I had forgotten when I
that I had when I was a child that sort
of got lost maybe
um
as I was getting older was brought back
because of this play and I'm quite
thankful for that really and it's back
again and I'm I'm seeing the world in a
different way again you know
eventually the two main characters must
part ways but it's not the kind of
farewell normally portrayed in Tales of
this sort
you really have this hope that there's
going to be this incredibly climactic
goodbye moment
and it just doesn't happen that moment
is um
you could hear a pin drop it's
some I think for some audience members
disappointing because you go oh I really
wanted him to to look back and say bye
and and have that moment but it's
so much more
a realistic and true to animal behavior
and be I think satisfying because
what we do in that moment is we create a
trust
where
the Tiger's gone
you're okay now
you're okay I can go it's very truthful
isn't it like
here there's somebody who helped me
survive
hardest part of my life
don't even get a chance to say goodbye
to that person the way I want to
and from the way audiences are reacting
to the show these performers won't be
saying goodbye to Broadway anytime soon
CBS Saturday morning Jamie wax New York
so Phantom left us what last week and
now Life of Pi comes in here they come
oh my God cannot wait to see that I
remember my brother first telling me
about the book
20 years ago and I read it it changes
you I mean it really is wonderful so
it's nice to see the development now
from the film to the Broadway play and I
love that the puppeteers are not hidden
and you can see them and see what
they're actually doing and they're
getting awarded for it yeah that's the
best part they're being recognized look
how amazing and just that short span of
seeing them on the screen here how
realistic that tiger looked